Okay guys so it's been quite a while since the first chopper episode
And a lot of you have been asking am I still pursuing this challenge
And the answer is yes
But the pandemic and an injury I had hasn't made it easy.
But during the last few months I have been able to practice more
So now it's time for an update on my progress!
Today I will be practicing irregular with Otto
Lets start with a short warm-up!
That was perfect!
Now the big reveal...
Emil is the real Sensei!
All this time!
Okay that was nice
But unfortunately those were just some highlights
If we look at my chopping development
I'm still doing a lot of easy mistakes
And it's hard to be consistent with the chops
Yeah I shouldn't miss the first one
But at the same time my chop has also improved quite a bit
There is a lot more spin in the chops right now
Even the Sensei had to admit this a few times during our session!
Aaaah, lift it!
But now let's get on to the exercise
Which Otto is very kind to explain to you!
Emil is going to hit to this area
So Otto doesn't have to move his legs
Yes!
And I will hit anywhere
So Emil has to move his legs!
In this exercise Otto hits the first ball to my backhand
And after that it's free
The reason why I like this exercise
Is that it demonstrates a real game situation
Much better than regular exersises
Just like in a real match
In this exercise you don't know where the ball is coming
So you have to be ready for everything
And even though the rallies aren't as long as in regular exercises
It can be really useful for your game play to practice irregular
The chop is looking quite good today Emil!
Three steps:
1. Chop
2. Lift
3. Smash!
Good combo!
Good
That's my combo!
That's also a good combo!
If we look at a few things that I clearly need to improve a lot more
The first thing is my footwork
You are way too far away
Yeah it seems so
You should take a step closer
In many situations I'm staying too far away from the ball
So I'm not able to do a proper shot
I think most of your mistakes come when you don't move enough
You really have to be on the top of your feet
So you really have to get your body behind the ball
If you compare the previous shot with this one
You can see that by taking just a small adjusting move
I'm able to make a much better shot
The second problem that I noticed
Was the difficulty to be in the right starting position for the next shot
I didn't really know should I be ready
To take the next shot with my backhand or my forehand
And as you see in these clips
I was too often waiting with the wrong side
In that especially
You were waiting for the forehand
Then I hit to your backhand
It's hard to chop
So I think you should be more ready for the backhand
More like somehow here
Now it helped!
It's really hard but it feels that I would need to find some
Golden middle way to be ready on both sides after every shot
Now I was in the wrong!
It's not as simple as it looks!
No it's not!
The third thing that felt really difficult
was to hit a no spin ball after doing some chops
The problem here is that the long pimple rubber reacts very differently
To a hard spin ball compared to a no spin ball
It's so different when there is no spin!
Yeah you haven't really practiced that yet
That was good!
Surprisingly good!
That was a good chop from the no spin
Yeah that was good
That's the right way
All in all it feels that I have definitely improved from the first episode
And chopping feels better now
But there is obviously still so much to learn
To get things right with this playing style
It just requires a lot more practice.
Thanks!